well good evening and welcome everybody
this is a very responsive audience
already I can see that that's wonderful
the university lecture is a very special
night on the academic calendar a night
when the columbia university is able to
hear from some of our most distinguished
scholars and teachers and tonight is no
exception to that it is my distinct
pleasure to be able to introduce dr.
linda free who is the delmar professor
of public health and a professor of
medicine and the Dean of the of
Columbia's mailman School of Public
Health Columbia's academic community is
committed to advancing the frontiers of
knowledge and addressing the most urgent
issues of our time we value social
responsibility public service and being
good citizens in a democratic society
and in every way that matters Columbia
is truly a global University where
multidisciplinary approaches are used to
better understand the world's most
complex problems and you will see a
wonderful example of that kind of work
tonight Linda is that rare scholar whose
accomplishments are so diverse that her
career stands as a powerful expression
of each one of these values she is a
Jerian Titian an epidemiologist a
world-renowned scientist and author of
over 350 peer-reviewed articles a member
of the Institute of Medicine of the
National Academy of Sciences she is the
world's recognized authority on the
causes of frailty in older people she
has been a mentor to many and an
invaluable teacher to even more in a
time when others were simply talking
about the importance of diversity in the
medical profession she was actively
taking steps at John Hopkins to make it
happen providing leadership for an
institutional transformation that
supported equity and inclusiveness for
women men and underrepresented
minorities well at Johns Hopkins she
pioneered multidisciplinary approaches
to developing the science of healthy
aging by four
collaborations among the schools of
medicine public health and nursing her
wide-ranging scholarship and research
have explored how we can improve the
personal health of individuals who are
living longer and how we can enhance the
positive impact of an aging adult
population on society as a whole Linda
is a co-founder of experience Corps an
initiative dedicated to engaging older
adults as tutors and mentors for grade
school children which is now operating
in 22 US cities the United States
Congress has named her a quote living
legend in medicine if you know Linda you
know this is not just another research
topic for her this is a mission a life
mission her work in 2008 Linda assumed
the deanship of the mailman School of
Public Health mailman with its fact with
with its 300 faculty working in more
than 100 countries is an institution
that has been a leader in responding to
the problems of maternal and infant
mortality the AIDS crisis in its early
stages climate change and health and
emerging preparedness in the emergency
preparedness in the wake of September 11
Linda is building on those strengths
with her commitment to setting a public
health agenda for aging she is a member
of the World Economic Forum's Global
Agenda Council and the council on an
aging world a member of the MacArthur
and network on an aging society and the
chair of Mayor Bloomberg's commission on
the role of higher education in creating
new york as an age-friendly City and
working with the late dr. Robert Butler
Linda forged a partnership that will
bring the International longevity Center
to columbia and the mailman center early
next year with respect to social change
no technological innovation emerging in
Silicon Valley can claim as great and
impact
our lives as the fact that on average
Americans are living 30 to 40 years
longer than we did just a century ago 20
years from now one in five Americans
will be aged 65 or older the historic
this historic demographic shift must
inform society's decisions about housing
employment economic growth and of course
medical care in her lecture titled
longer lives in an aging society needs
opportunities and creating win-wins dr.
Freid will talk to us not only about the
challenges we will have to confront but
also about the untapped social capital
that as fast that is fast developing as
a result of this demographic shift and
the enormous potential than an aging
society has to offer it is my special
privilege to present to you dr. Linda
free
good evening its my special privilege to
be here this evening and to have been
asked to do something that rarely
happens in one's career which is to try
and tell you the story of science which
is what I was asked to do to tell you
about a scientific journey there are
many in the room who can do the same but
the challenge was that I was given was
to try and create for you the fabric of
a scientific career and to go beyond the
opportunities that were usually given to
show you one or another thread so I'd
like to start in trying to tell you
about that journey by with exactly the
data that provo steel just led off with
these are data that actually changed my
own career direct directions a couple of
decades ago when I saw them this these
data are about human history and what
you can see in this slide is that from
the beginnings of time all the way on
the bottom left until nineteen hundred
on the bottom right in the world human
life expectancy was approximately 24
years of age that means that at Birth
people could expect to live 24 years on
average and then across the world
starting just before 1900 human life
expectancy started to rise and worldwide
it has more than doubled in just the
last hundred years this is breathtaking
transformation of all of us as a world
in the US as Provost steel just said the
same thing has happened it started a
little bit earlier but in nineteen
hundred children born in nineteen
hundred could expect to live fifty years
on average fast-forward a hundred years
later and that has almost doubled to 80
years and is rising
very dramatic I saw these data and
thought about the implications and in
fact we're seeing them play out in 1900
with life expectancy at 50 years people
who were 65 and older constituted only
four percent of the u.s. population ten
years ago it was twelve percent and by
2030 it will be up to twenty percent of
the u.s. population picture Florida the
distribution of age in Florida for the
US and the same thing is happening in
the world here you see in the lighter
shades people 60 and older as a
proportion of the total world population
in 2010 on the left and you can see that
it's far less than twenty percent and by
2050 in the bottom the lighter shades
which are people 60 and older will
constitute about forty-five percent of
the world's population this is the
success of a century of public health
medicine education and improved economic
status this is the success of all of our
endeavors is that we get to live these
longer lives and I haven't met a single
individual who didn't want to experience
that success myself included as
individuals we all hope to have a long
life and yet societally we're
experiencing a great paradox and the
paradox is that we are discussing those
societally as though population aging is
a big problem for us in fact one we
can't afford the dominant perception if
you read the paper of the implications
of an aging society is that we have aged
into a deficit situation of high needs
high costs and low contributions from
the older part of the population in fact
if you look at the paper as recently as
yesterday you see these headlines this
is the way we are expressing this
success of our investments over the last
century now who constitutes an aging
population it's our family it's our
grandparents it's our parents it's our
kids and it's us and so is that the
equation that we really want to live
with do we have to live with it these
are the questions that I have spent
several decades trying to answer
stimulated by looking at those first
data that you saw about this dramatic
transformation in human history that we
are currently living through and is
unprecedented so what if we could
rebalance our perceived costs and
benefits what if we could invest through
knowledge and values in creating a
society where the costs and benefits of
the challenges and the needs of aging
are counterbalanced by an understanding
of the wind winds that come with it what
if we could see those win wins what
would the implications at a policy and
societal decision-making level be if we
could see that balance so my career has
been spent since I first saw those data
and they took my breath away about how
the world was changing learning the
questions I wanted to ask and trying to
find the answers with the privilege of
working in universities that permit
tackling things that are not necessarily
popular but matter for all of us and so
I have lat asked over the course of the
last 20 plus years a series of questions
in parallel which I learned over time
the answers to one could help solve the
problems of the other and so I'm going
to tell you about those parallel
questions and how they inform solutions
for each other in the coming 40 minutes
and the questions that I saw as to how
to rebalance those scales included the
following for people living longer live
how can we add life to years how can we
ensure that we have done our best jobs
so that people who are living longer
lives are healthy during that time and
one key part of being healthy is whether
we can prevent a condition called
frailty then if we knew how to do that
how could we bring that out to people in
all communities so they could benefit
from it and experience that healthy
aging we're imagining and we know that
people who are healthy as they get older
actually are a huge economic boon to
society in many ways there's more recent
data to support that and then if we
could do that could we capitalize on the
huge capabilities that older adults
bring or could bring and create win-wins
new kinds of social institutions that
could help reposition those scales
beneficial for older adults beneficial
for society and ultimately if we did
that if we can envision it if we
implemented it would there be a positive
return on investment for society for
making that happen so I'm going to try
and tell you these parallel stories and
bring them together at the end and I
will start with one place which is that
in the 1980s as many of you in the room
know there was a dramatic article
published that proposed that the major
public health and clinical goal for an
aging society needed to be must be to
learn how to add life two years the term
that was applied was that we had to
figure out how to compress morbidity how
to prevent illness disease frailty to
the latest points in the human lifespan
so that people could live those years
healthy my journey is expressed in this
one picture with a focus first on the
science of frailty prevention what it is
what we could do about it is it
preventable and then with that
information
and sometimes in parallel whether we
could design new kinds of roles for
older adults that could prevent frailty
and some of its consequences like
disability in other words create healthy
aging while also permitting older adults
to give back across generations and thus
activate the social capital of the huge
numbers of older adults in society and
ultimately to ask about return on
investment so I'm going to start at the
center of the picture and then try and
show you how we framed it now in the
1980s when I was in training and then
went on the faculty at Johns Hopkins
frailty in older adults was very much on
the many people's tongues because it was
very clear particularly in geriatric
medicine that frail older adults were
the highest risk subset of older adults
vulnerable to bad outcomes death
disability Falls and geriatric medicine
which I was trained in after I saw the
data that I showed you was very much
focused on how we could prevent those
bad outcomes I spent many years actually
trying to think about that and to it
emerged to me that some of the key
questions we needed to understand to
find the answers was to understand even
who was really frail what was causing it
and if we knew what was causing it how
we could prevent it and whether it was
preventable clinical knowledge suggested
that we knew what frail older adults
were and there was a continuum a
spectrum from very resilient to very
frail as people got older the their
reserves and resilience seemed to
decline so that people who were
resilient and independent we're very
different than people who might have
looked healthy but actually turned out
to be very vulnerable in the face of
stressors and we're at high risk of
becoming frail and clearly these two
groups if you wanted to prevent frailty
where the place where you would start
very much the perspective of public
health science to find the place to do
prevention now I fast forward 10 years
if you don't mind many studies later
after thinking about these questions it
became very clear to me as a result of
the research that I did that despite the
definitions that were in the literature
frailty was not the same as being sick
with any disease frailty was not the
same as having a bunch of diseases and
frailty was not the same as being
disabled and having difficulty doing
some of the tasks in your life but
rather I began to think that frailty was
actually a condition a clinical
condition on to itself that it was a
distinct clinically recognizable entity
to test that because I think it was like
it is actually the common perception if
you close your eyes and try and imagine
a frail person we'll probably all say
the same thing and we'll say somebody
who's maybe thin a little slow down low
activity not so much energy and weak or
some subsets of that but it took me many
years to get there through many studies
and it became very clear that it was not
any one of those but actually the
combination of them that seemed to point
to people who were at very high risk and
very vulnerable and from that puzzling
for several more years over why that
list was there why did those things Co
occur in people I proposed in a day of a
hoss that there was actually a vicious
cycle going on which was not about a
disease but it actually was an
independent process and this messy
picture is all about a very vicious
cycle which I call the cycle of frailty
and can start at any point but has to do
in the right-hand side with people
losing muscle mass as they get older if
you go down to the bottom right
declining strength and declining fitness
which is called vo2 max
and if you go to the left people slowing
down less walking speed and then all the
way to the left they cut back on their
physical activity and lo and behold for
reasons that seem to be very
physiologically driven there is an
imbalance so that even at low activity
levels in the bottom left a subset of
older adults are not taking in enough
nutrition in the top right and they lose
weight they get weaker and you get the
cycle going round yet again so this was
a proposal that I put forward in the
late 90s after now working on this
question for many many years and fast
forward a few more years and we have
been able over the course of a number of
studies to demonstrate that in fact
there is a strong reason to believe that
this is the truth that there is a
syndrome a clinical syndrome of if you
will shrinking and slowing and weakness
with low activity and low energy low
sense of energy and that this may well
be driven by dysregulation of energy
production and use in the body that's
affecting and propelling all of these
different manifestations and in fact we
have demonstrated that this behaves a
lot like a medical syndrome in fact
identically with a medical syndrome
independent of diseases or the aging
process which may kick it off and we've
demonstrated that people have this
profile at very high risk just as we
hypothesize for a range of very bad
outcomes for dying in 18 months for
becoming disabled losing independence
for falling so that not only can we
define it but we can say that it matters
for people's well-being now that may be
all well and good but if it doesn't
occur in anybody then it's somewhat
irrelevant but in fact we've
demonstrated that seven percent of older
adults living in the community actually
meet our criteria for frailty and
that there is reason to think that
having this picture above the water line
of being frail carries with it some very
serious worries in fact those with that
above the waterline picture as I said
are at high risk if something happens
you get the flu you end up in the
hospital you have decreased ability to
manage those kinds of stressors
physically and much higher risk of
becoming more disabled and having very
slow recovery this has many clinical
implications which I'm not going to go
into tonight but it also raises
questions if this is a distinct entity
how do we take go inferential e to the
next question which is is there
something under the water line that's
causing it and so I've spent with my
colleagues many years since then trying
to understand what might be driving this
and to present the evidence as to what's
going on and I'm going to summarize that
very quickly so I can take you to the
picture frame so this issue could be
summed up in this syndrome of frailty by
showing you the vicious cycle at the top
of the slide which you've already seen
this vicious cycle of loss of muscle
mass declines and strength decrease
energy slowing down low physical
activity this presentation marks people
who seem to be very vulnerable to bad
outcomes which is that horizontal
rectangle but the question is what's
causing it and we hypothesize that there
might be a number of causes at the
physiologic level where systems were not
working right and even at the deep
molecular and cellular levels and so
I'll show you a little of the resulting
evidence but it's this whole picture
which constitutes a clinical syndrome so
many many research studies later
developing hypotheses about what might
be driving this picture we've
demonstrated in fact
there are a lot of physiologic systems
that function abnormally when people are
frail decrease muscle mass I said that
already inflammation worse immune
function bad heart rate reactions to
stressors which are called which come
from the autonomic nervous system poor
clotting if you're bleeding impaired
glucose and insulin resistance perhaps
what you see when people are diabetic
but perhaps something else that looks
similar and associated with aging and
frailty anemia hormones out of whack and
low micronutrients among a list that's
actually much longer now what are these
all doing together we have demonstrated
that the likelihood of these not working
right when people are frail is very high
and the likelihood of many of them not
working right is the case i'll show you
a couple of snapshots one here from my
colleague ravi varadhan is looking at
cortisol levels in people who are frail
in red and not frail in black these are
older women who are 85 to 95 years of
age and there is what's called a diurnal
variation so that cortisol which is your
stress hormone varies in its levels
across the day and in the middle of the
day and the afternoon is really high and
then it decreases when you go to sleep
well what you can see is that the red
peak and the top graph is not as high as
the black peak and so people who are
frail although it looks insignificant
it's not clinically people who are frail
actually have a very blunted normal
cortisol variation and in the bottom
graph you can see that it's the cortisol
is much slower to rise in the people who
are frail and takes longer to decline so
the function of a hormone that we rely
on to manage our well-being every single
day seems a little out of whack
similarly under stress you see huge
variations so here's one example from
studies we just completed of glucose
tolerance test response civet e
in frailty again for women 85 to 95
years of age these are data from my
colleague and Coppola at the University
of Pennsylvania and what you see is that
at the zero point on the bottom left all
the women in the study started out the
same they drank a glucose load just like
you would do if you are getting a
clinical test to see if you were
diabetic and then the differences
started so that the red line indicates
the high surge of glucose which was not
well regulated in women who were frail
while in women who were not frail or pre
frail in the black and green they
managed the glucose stressor very well
so the responses of individual systems
seem to be a little out of whack when
your frail but in addition what we found
is that the more systems aren't working
the greater the likelihood of being
frail and the relationship is not a
straight line and biologically that has
a lot of importance the relationship is
nonlinear or curvilinear you can see
that as you go from zero systems not
working on the left 25 or more not
working on the right now that pattern
actually is consistent with the
nonlinear dynamics of multi system
dysregulation those nonlinear dynamics
mean that the whole is greater than some
of the part and the more systems that
aren't working the more the problem
spins out of control essentially and you
have the potential to emerge into a new
state of being a different physiologic
status as a function of all the systems
not working right what would that look
like well here are those bottom two
circles i showed you before i just shown
figuratively the physiologic systems
that might underlie being frail and on
the bottom the molecular and genetic
systems and interesting we know that
within circles the circles mutually
regulate each other because resilient
people physically
have very tight networks of mutual
regulation and actually across the
circles of different systems we actually
regulate each other and if you try and
portray that with all these silly arrows
what you get the feeling of very quickly
is a safety net and in fact that's what
resilient healthy people rely on is this
physical safety net of all our systems
working together in mutually regulating
each other if you were to peel off a few
of those because they weren't working
well you could very quickly feel that
we're losing our safety net of
resilience so in fact what we are
learning is that this dysregulation of a
lot of systems could result in fraying
of the complex networks that make us
resilient give us reserves make it
possible for us to bounce back from an
illness or after stressors and we've
shown is related both to the
presentation of being frail as well as
to the vulnerabilities for bad outcomes
that seem to go along with that so on
the frailty side we have demonstrated
some of it conclusively some of it
intriguingly that people as they get
older are at risk of becoming frail if
there are many physical systems that
work together stop working so tightly
together if their function isn't quite
as finely tuned as it used to be and
this is really a multi-system problem
now there may be a deep underlying
biologic cause of that perhaps
dysregulation of energy production in
ourselves but the many systems involve
suggest that just targeting one system
for prevention or a fix may not do it
and in fact we have to find causes if we
want to prevent frailty we have to find
causes that can affect many systems so
where could we look for clues well I'll
show you one the clue I'll start with
because it helps open the rest of the
story is about low physical activity
and in fact we have demonstrated that
low physical activity actually is
predictive of who becomes frail and very
interestingly going back to these three
circles low physical activity in the top
left has been shown to make almost every
system in our body work better from
building muscle to actually making the
modoch mitochondria which produce energy
and yourselves work better and in fact
we know at the public health level that
what we do matters as we get older so we
can improve health outcomes dramatically
if people stay more active physically
and cognitively socially engaged there's
been a lot of research on that over the
last 20 years so how do we take all this
and wrap it up to think about how to
actually bring the conditions for
healthy aging and preventing frailty out
into the community so that we can help
all people across their lifespan and as
they're getting older stay healthy
whether it turns out there a lot of
challenges and so I'm going to switch
from the individual to our society for a
few minutes in conclusion and tell you
the other part of the story and the
challenges have to do with our
experiences in our society right now as
we shift from work roles to retirement
which if you survey older adults clearly
can mean loss of purpose loss of social
connectedness loss of opportunities to
stay physically and mentally active and
connected and people generally don't
seem to get enrolled in exercise
programs and if they do they don't stay
that long that's one part of staying
active and engaged and in particular the
people who need it most don't seem to
have access to it but at the same time
people are seeking to really make a
difference as they get older many people
it's part of the characteristics of
maturing is to feel the deep need to
make a difference for the generations
behind us and yet older people as they
tire report very few meaningful roles
with which to make a difference at the
same time the irony of course is that
the capabilities of older adults are
virtually untapped we have the best
educated healthiest cohort of older
adults in the history of the world alive
right now with time to give and a desire
to give back and leave the world a
better place and too many of them report
no place to do that and at the same time
we have profound profound societal unmet
needs including the needs to ensure that
our next generation is well-educated and
able to participate as a responsible
productive contributing members of a
democratic society we also as you see in
the paper every day seem to have
tremendous fears of competition for
resources between an aging society
between older adults and children and
their needs so where are we well big
questions increased life expectancy
people are going to be living a third of
their lives after retirement and we're
going to have very shortly as many older
adults in the world and certainly in our
country as children these are game
changers what will we do with them
question that occurred to me 22 years
ago was is there a way to rebalance
those scales could we create high-impact
win-wins for an aging society in fact we
must find those win-wins we must ones
that benefit older adults so that they
can live healthy into older age and at
the same time harness the societal
benefit of having world or adults around
so I posed the question to myself of
what if we could create new meaningful
generative ways generative to make
difference for society in the
generations behind us for people to stay
engaged so that we could harness the
benefits of being an aging society and
simultaneously find ways to promote
healthy and successful aging if we could
figure these models out then we would
have a win-win we could create roles
that would serve
both all generations and improve and
create a more resilient and stronger
society where to start well one place to
start of course is that it turns out the
intergenerational transfers at the level
of individuals families and society are
the fabric of a resilient society that's
a conversation in itself so I'll leave
it at that but if you take that model
then an obvious place to me to start was
to think about how to deploy older
adults in very high impact models in
public elementary schools high-impact
models Evans based models to ensure the
success of our children and
simultaneously could we hide within
those roles because people sign up to
make a difference they often don't sign
up to exercise could we hide within
those roles ways to help people stay
healthy and so out of that question came
an idea which is now called experience
core I designed it in the early 90s then
had a pleasure of partnering with
somebody named mark Friedman who was who
had a similar idea and we completed it
and did the first national demonstration
in 1996 and experience score is now
operating in over 20 cities around the
u.s. what is it well it's an
evidence-based model for volunteer 60
and older serving in public elementary
schools performing meaningful important
roles that the principal's say meet
their greatest unmet needs for the
children's success committing 15 or more
hours a week through a full school year
so these are non-trivial high-intensity
roles with a critical mass of older
adults in every school the critical mass
is determined by the principal but it's
enough older adults to shift the
outcomes for all the children in
kindergarten through third grade in the
right direction and we hid inside of
that I hid very carefully with my
colleagues the
sign a public-health design to increase
physical social and cognitive activity
along with the ability make a difference
as key causes of better or worse health
outcomes in older people here's a
picture one picture of experience core
at work we have designed over the last
15 years a number of high impact roles
for older adults and deployed them both
in Baltimore where I with my colleagues
built a model program and now throughout
the country these roles can be
one-on-one they can be one on a few they
can be groups together but the theory
was starting from the left that older
adults would sign up to make a real
difference if they thought this was a
program that would have high impact that
we could deploy them in the orange
through both working with individual or
small groups of children to improve in
the middle column their literacy skills
their readiness to learn and to support
their behaviors and lead to improved
aggregate performance and in the bottom
by putting a critical mass of older
adults in every school to actually
create a social capital pathway that
would improve the ability of teachers to
teach support school climate and
actually enhance and amplify the
benefits of what the volunteers were
doing individually early results for the
kids if we weren't seeing this then we
would stop there but the early results
are very positive looking at the impact
of experience core on kindergarten
through 3rd graders we're seeing
dramatic decreases thirty to fifty
percent decreases in office referrals
and suspensions in these young children
with similarly impressive improvements
in vocabulary reading and math scores on
standardized testing sufficient to make
the principal's think that this is
critical enough for school systems to
invest in the program
but what are we doing beyond that well
this is a picture of some of the
volunteers in one public elementary
school in Baltimore a few years ago with
the then mayor of Baltimore now the
governor of Maryland in the middle and
by looking at them you can appreciate
what the power of having an aging
society deployed in new kinds of roles
and social institutions might look like
because the issue really is how to
amplify the capabilities of older adults
into social capital Robert Putnam said a
few years ago actually in 1993 that we
have dilemmas in our society increasing
dilemmas of collective action we are not
organized to utilize the aggregate
weight of what people together could
accomplish and that this is a
precondition for economic development
and effective government and makes
possible if we organize to support
social capital makes possible the
achievement of certain ends that would
not be attainable in its absence and so
we hypothesized actually that we might
be able to harness social capital in a
novel way in the experience core in fact
older adults are the only increasing
natural resource in the world the only
one and so how can we all benefit from
that well experience court is actually
the first intentional experiment to
create social capital from its potential
on a large scale through roles that
people would come to to make a
difference and stay in because they were
and the theory is exemplified in this
photo where we tried through the
investment as a sport civic society to
transform potential social capital into
collective on the left into collective
impact on the right our research shows
that in fact it is generative desire
that causes older adults to sign up
and that after they have been in the
program for a year they report that they
feel fulfilled in their generative
desires because of the differences
they've seen in the children they're
working with and they report that it
takes time to get there so people are
drawn to help out they love the
experience and at the same time we have
hidden inside of it a public health
approach to preventing frailty and
disability and so I'll conclude by
showing a few of the punch lines of the
potential of that the first is that in
the we assume that people would come in
the left hand side to make a difference
we designed the program very carefully
as public health professionals to hide
within that those roles to make a
difference ways to increase physical
cognitive and social activity of older
adults and we hypothesized that because
each of those four things actually
matter in terms of health outcomes that
if we put them all together into one
program we might have the potential for
really impacting on people's health and
in theory we would first see
improvements for example in the middle
set of circles in strength and if we
designed it right in mental function as
well as other things and downstream we
hopefully will see the ability to
compress morbidity in terms of decrease
frailty and Falls and disability i'm
going to show you to conclude a few
snapshots from the middle at the left
hand and middle column and a randomized
trial is currently in process to look at
the long-term outcomes on the right so
we have demonstrated although i don't
have time to show it to you today
improve significant improvements in
physical cognitive and social activity
and supports for participants in
experience score and that people report
feeling stronger higher energy less
depressive symptoms i'm going to show
you a couple of things from the physical
activity and our evaluation very early
eval
uation of whether in fact the design we
created to stimulate mental function has
any prayer of working so the first piece
of evidence is that by asking people to
come to a public elementary school three
to five days a week if they were not
active before him by the time they get
to the school by the time they go up the
stairs by the time they get up and down
from those little old chairs they
actually have done enough exercise in
the course of a week to earn themselves
the same amount of energy expenditure as
we seek in exercise trials not bad and
then we have demonstrated in the last
year that in fact in only four to eight
months of follow-up if you look at older
Americans who are have normal mental
function but it's at the lower end that
we are seeing highly substantial
improvements in their executive function
and don't have time to show you the data
but I will say why is that important
well executive function is important for
many reasons it's all about our ability
to handle complex tasks plan initiate
manage solve problems and it's integral
to the ability at any age to live
independently in addition there's very
intriguing early evidence that
age-related changes an executive
function actually predict future
declines in memory raising the question
of whether if you can slow or prevent
declines an executive function if you
could also prevent loss of memory those
are unanswered questions but my
colleague Michelle Carlson just
published a study of eight experience
core participants african-american women
sixty-eight years of average and
compared them to women of similar
backgrounds twelve years of education on
average and looked at the eight the
brain outcomes on functional MRI scans
of those experience Corps volunteers
compared to the controls and what she
found
was that in this program which is
designed to stimulate particularly
executive function that in fact after
six months the experience corps
volunteers brains lit up in new places
that's the red compared to the
comparison group that did not light up
at all now what does that mean it means
that these people's brains are newly
activated in certain areas and in fact
the areas the prefrontal cortex and the
anterior cingulate cortex match the
areas of improvement in executive
function that we saw in a larger group
so it would appear that in fact there is
great potential from approaches like
this that go out into our communities
that engage people to simultaneously
from a public health point of view
design interventions to keep people
healthier and perhaps to improve their
mental function markedly improved mental
executive function over four to eight
months and brain activation which
suggests that experienced core supports
brain plasticity into the oldest stages
so I'll end with a couple of comments
one is that experience core for me in my
scientific journey has been the frame
around research to understand how to
help people stay healthy as they get
older that's all of us it seems to have
the potential and the dimensions I just
told you to add life to years although
the definitive trial is in progress and
we won't know for a couple of years and
it seems to have the potential to bring
to fruition some of the benefits of
being an aging society and perhaps to
help create a model for many other
social institutions we may need to
rebalance our positive scales so and by
a punch line and the punch line is well
is there a positive return on this
investment and in fact I'll make two
points one is the
that we have done economic studies
showing in fact that investing in older
adults to be an experience score appears
to be highly cost effective or
cost-saving if less than 1% of the
children who are reached less than 1%
end up graduating from high school who
otherwise would not have and these are
likely extremely conservative estimates
and with those conservative estimates
all school systems have the potential to
improve the small amount there are other
many other returns on investment and so
I'll end with a small video would you
please roll a video this video is
actually about the experience Corps
program in Philadelphia and it is about
returns on investment please a
disturbingly large number of our
children are reading below grade level
in communities across America experience
or mobilizes the Thai talent and
experience of older adults to help
children improve their literacy skills
and succeed in school when I found out
that I can really do something to help
kids learn and to see their faces when
they really find out that oh I'm reading
now it is such enjoyment for me just to
be out be among them we're tapping into
this incredible power of older adult
volunteerism it really creates an energy
within the school that really provides
the tutoring power but also affects the
teachers and an overall culture climate
of the school the school like
pennypacker we've got 14 members on the
team that equates to almost 200 hours of
service a week the children that were
chosen to be tutored by our
intergenerational tutors were those
children that we felt had a lot of
academic issues they needed a lot of
one-on-one we needed a lot of care and
attention fact that you have consistency
you have love you have all these extra
people who come in and give the children
the one on one of the teachers can't
the academic impact was tremendous she
has near a banner and she helps me all
we better his teacher thought that
Elliot could use some help in reading
thank you Miss goes when I retired life
changes you used to go into work every
day and with this program it gives you a
whole new meaning to your life working
with the children I think the children
see all of us as role models because
they see something that they can strive
for something that they can achieve
themselves and they realize that your
friend which they definitely have a more
positive attitude to it older people I
think that this program has has changed
the community to a great extent it's
uplifting when I read the newspaper and
they talk about the school system
instead of sitting there drinking coffee
I feel so much better when I can't say
that I'm trying one child at a time so
I'll end on that note with many thanks
to provo steel and president Bollinger
for the opportunity to show you how far
we've gotten i agree with Robert Frost
that I've never started a poem yet whose
end I knew and writing a poem is
discovering and and the conditions for
discovery exists in great universities
and so my thanks really go to my many
colleagues with whom I've had the
privilege over the last 20 odd years of
doing this work and the people who have
inspired and including Robert Butler and
Jack row who with me have helped
envision the move of the International
longevity center to Columbia and finally
with great thanks for the import of
university to take the long view on the
issues we have to tackle to be a
stronger society and a greater world
thank you
I'm going to thank Linda for that
wonderful talk it's you accomplished so
much in a single talk it's
scientifically illuminating it's it's
hopeful and it's inspirational so I
really want to thank you for that I'll
be inviting everybody in a minute to
join us in the faculty room in back of
the stage here for a reception but I
think we do have time for a few
questions that people have them there
are microphones in the aisle there and
so if anybody would like to get more
from linda this is an opportunity to do
that so first thank you very much Dean
freed that was very exciting as a
scientific story and a social story
about two questions one in some of the
early research about experience cord if
I remember correctly you talked about in
the design how important it was to train
the volunteers to do things they had not
done before to in fact stimulate new
skills and new parts of their brain I'm
wondering if you could talk more about
that and also in your role as chair of
the age for the New York City
educational commission do you see a role
for the University in helping to train
older people to take new roles either as
volunteers or as business people or in
other capacities that would use
different skills that they had
previously so there are many answers to
your questions but i'll try and briefly
give you three one is that with my
colleagues who were Korean neurologists
of aging and gerontologists and
geriatricians we actually very carefully
over the period of years designed roles
to stimulate different parts of people's
mental function in ways that would
actually be relevant to daily life and
if they were relevant to what they had
to do in daily life our theory was that
then they'd go
and use those skills in many ways and
the benefit of what they were doing in
the schools would get amplified we seem
to be seeing that that is panning out we
the dramatic differences that I showed
you in terms of cognition and in terms
of brain activation are to my knowledge
unprecedented in terms of interventions
a both behavioral and pharmacologic and
so I think the stimulation really that
people are getting draws from the
science the experience in the theory
it's one example of the importance of
universities institutions of higher
education and visioning to go to your
second question how we transform to an
aging world and there are many ways in
which i think universities can
contribute to that I've been really
privileged to be chairing the mayor's
Commission and city council speakers
Commission on this set of issues because
in fact New York City like all major
cities understands that pack elections
are going to age choose that I presented
today are relevant for society so what
could universities be doing I think they
range everywhere from the deep desire of
older adults to engage in lifelong
learning and to have many new venues to
do that universities are magnets
appropriately so for those opportunities
but many universities are not really
organized to to really engage with older
adults and so part of the challenge for
our future is to figure out where the
opportunities might be for new kinds of
wind winds there are many other answers
to that question but that that combined
with the knowledge we generate that can
create new social institutions that can
really also support win wins I think are
the first two roles
yes
he's going to hand you a microphone so i
think that will help everybody hear your
question i am sold on this program that
you have developed i do see in our local
school system they're seniors who are
accepted reluctantly as volunteers but
they are just you know assigned to some
meaningless java i see the / the point
of your program is to focus the energy
to have a purpose to do something which
is you have studied has some relations
with taking care of frailty my question
pertaining to this part is dutra ed does
i'm sure i should read the literature
does your program try to find one-to-one
correlation between the skills that the
seniors have and the tasks that they are
assigned to them and n here in the other
aspect of that would be what are their
needs have frailty knees that would help
them in that respect now i want to ask
another question outside of this why
just focus on elementary school
theoretically at least do you see it a
bikini apply to other areas of life
thank you so i'll take the last one
first the reason to start with
elementary schools is twofold one you
have to start somewhere and the end the
and if you start somewhere then you want
to do it right so you truly make a
difference and you're not spread to them
and the second reason is the evidence
that children have to be succeeding by
third grade to succeed in life and so if
we could deploy we have to start
somewhere if we're going to choose one
thing we'd make sure that our children
were ready to succeed
the rest of their career is that the
place to stop I doubt it but we if we
you also can't just deploy anybody into
public schools or any school without an
appropriately designed and structured
program or you can do more harm than
good and so it requires a real
investment in design so that you're
confident that you're not wasting
anybody's time and you'll truly make a
difference if you're one more question I
had a few this is so eliminating this
talk and it's raised more questions and
I you know would love to present one I
wanted to ask right off the bat we are
part of a greater metropolitan area here
in New York and one of the school
systems that is tragically brought into
focus is Newark has there been any
outreach between you know your group the
experience core and Newark and vice vice
versa by you know the mayor over there
so unfortunately I probably don't know
the answer to that there's now a
national experience core organization in
Washington which is doing that work and
regretfully I don't know I mean part of
the I'll just comment though the part of
the challenge of creating new kinds of
social institutions particularly if they
cross generations is that we do not have
ready mechanisms to invest in them they
actually I can tell you many stories
about it but they're very hard the
resources are very hard to come by and
the ability to sustain them is even
harder okay I just had a few more
comments I hope you don't mind I've been
involved with the science fair in the
city of New York and there's a great
deal of talent with
youth but i also have witnessed
unfortunately that a number of these
students are not being properly guided
the ones who demonstrate the greatest
products are those who have been
fortunate enough to be able to access
university level to Turris while they
are still in high school but the others
do suffer so I do hope that somehow that
is brought across because there are far
too many teachers teaching subject
matter of which is alien to them and the
other thing I did want to point out
seems you're talking about older people
is have you considered an operations
research a think-tank kind of system to
bring some of that talent of these older
generational people to work on problems
of air day you know that you know
Congress is thinking of or the city or
state that's all thank you so I'll just
say I appreciate your comments those are
very long discussions but there's very
intriguing evidence in the cognitive
psychology realm that as we all get
older we're actually capable of a
certain kind of synthetic creativity
that leads us to see people like Nelson
Mandela or Gandhi solve a major societal
problems that advanced stages that those
of us when we were 20 couldn't have
figured out so figuring out how to do
that kind of thing tank approach we all
may benefit thank you well I I hate to
disappoint you you guys who have
obviously good questions as well but
maybe you can meet up with Linda in the
reception that is going to begin at this
point so let me just end by thanking you
again for a wonderful talk a wonderful
email please join us backstage
you